mientras recogen los escombros en la
ciudad de jenning las últimas Víctimas
de la incursión del jueves elevan a
decenas el número de palestinos Muertos
este año la mayoría por disparos de las
fuerzas de israelíes
la resistencia continuará hasta la
liberación de Palestina
pero para los grupos de Derechos Humanos
es una señal de una tendencia creciente
2022 ya fue uno de los años más
mortíferos desde el inicio del registro
de la ONU con más de 200 palestinos y 27
israelíes muertos en los territorios
ocupados de cisjordania el este de
Jerusalén y la franja de gaza un
derramamiento de sangre que se achaca al
uso excesivo de la fuerza israelí así
como al aumento de los asaltos de
colonos Jordania motivo por el que
muchos palestinos que viven allí bajo la
ocupación ilegal israelí responden
violentamente como en noviembre cuando
un hombre mató a cuchilladas a tres
colonos antes de recibir un disparo
quien quiera que haga daño a ciudadanos
israelíes no tiene donde esconderse lo
perseguiremos lo encontraremos donde
quiera que esté
desde la otra parte la falta de
responsabilidades se hizo evidente sin
consecuencias para los soldados de
Israel que mataron a la periodista del
yacira chairina o para los que
dispararon contra un niño palestino
nabud en diciembre por estar tirando
piedras el número de inclusiones
israelíes en ciudades y aldeas
palestinas aumentó con un bombardeo en
toda gaza a principios de agosto en
respuesta a un ataque con cohetes de
militantes
responsabilizamos plenamente al enemigo
sionista por esta tragedia Los Jóvenes
palestinos sólo han conocido la
ocupación militar y las políticas
represivas de la autoridad Palestina
creada como gobierno provisional hace
tres décadas tras el proceso de paz de
oslo hoy en día sin embargo muchos
acusan a sus dirigentes ya mayores de
haber perdido el contacto con la
realidad y culpan a la organización por
permitir la ocupación israelí hay una
montaña de corrupción exclusividad
coordinación ignorando la legitimidad Y
acabando con todos los referentes
elegidos democráticamente por el pueblo
palestino como consecuencia el año
pasado surgieron dos nuevos grupos
militantes a palestinos clave el
batallón de llenín y La Guarida de León
que se unen a la autoridad ya
establecida de jamás ahora los temores
aumentan para Israel y sus aliados con
el gobierno de extrema derecha de
Benjamín netanyahu advirtiendo que un
escuadrón terrorista de la yihad
islámica está en camino para atacar